yanny just kidnapped me and now i i'm
and and he told me okay
antonio just pretend everything is fine
just tell about the papers tell about
the memes
what's going on yannick we're gonna look
at pictures and go haha
all right we're back antonio's back
welcome back to meme review well how
dare you to assume i'm back
antonio never left
how's the channel going the channel's
going fine it's at
like 60 some thousand subscribers
60 million 60 million subscribers 60
million subscribers
this is not financial advice
he uses machine learning machine learns
me oh
it's still a bit like magic machine
learning honestly like you understand
everything it's still a bit like magic
you understand everything i don't i'm
not at youtube i don't
i don't even watch yannick i mean um
what
i don't even watch my own videos so yeah
password
mom can we have pie torch
we have pizza at home pie torch at home
psychic learn that was always the best
after matlab of course
and you know every time every time we do
this actually there's a
there's a matlab email coming up now
just for me
an email just just says just for me
where is the new matlab
2021 a pre-release it's going to be hard
for them
for all the matlab users to make
individual
releases yeah exactly there must be at
least like
seven matlab users in the world jim just
unsubscribed yesterday
major revenue draw yeah they have to
fire half the team 200 people
oh so you're a human yes
name every picture traffic lights
i was like i think that's genius i feel
enslaved
yeah it's genius it's so genius to do
that the first time i saw that i was
like
that's genius i don't have glasses
literally anything
if state is this interpretable ai
yeah what is this thing fuzzy logic what
is that
what is that i think that's right if you
if you write your code on wool
if you sew it on speaking of wool
oh yeah of course oh yeah because it's
uh this is uh it's christmas today it's
just christmas edition christmas
we're going to do a copy edition later
when are there cove with machine
learning memes
that was the effect of copied on machine
learning
we have conferences in gather talent uh
yeah
which is also also the virtual pretzels
that made me laugh in new york what's
the virtual threat
there was like um an event called okay
at
four we're gonna have virtual drinks and
pretzels
so in in gather town so there's a
function to follow someone if you click
on the name of someone you can follow
them
so i stalked a bunch of people if
someone walks by
you just follow them and it's super
creepy because it'll be like walking
and you'll just be always walking behind
them
i don't like like this run but i have to
say i have to say i quite enjoyed
gather town yeah i liked it i stopped a
bunch of people
it was like i was at my poster i wanted
to
talk to james martens now you're
watching james
and you're watching then every time he
was like oops
i have to go sorry sorry i have to i
have to go a little p
i have to go pee yeah sure
it would be funny if there's toilets in
gather town you know
are there so i don't know there are you
can also
you can only you can only like you know
the things you pee
like the things how's it called hey you
already know the urinal yeah
then you can only talk to the two on the
left and right
the video connection the video
connection activates
by the way uh thanks to all the discord
members who are largely responsible
for these memes thank you very much
bunch of criminals
double blind review gpt-3 paper
it's open ai who knew oh
my god that's how you do papers yeah
well gpt-3 is now the best paper in
europe
was it in europe like it was an europe's
i missed that i remember still last
last last year in europe's but you had
this uh banjo
person you know you know that guy
the the boxing the boxing he does boxing
professional boxing nice and even though
he does boxing
people just you know stay very close to
him yeah
just i mean desire to die like you know
the society desire to die they asked him
question and he was like i don't care i
just want to do a fight
and then anyone new at ai any new ai
technology
can it beat the stock market i think i
think yeah
i think i think this one this one this
new one this one you will
be able to beat the stock market
transformers will beat the stock market
you know that gpt3
you just ask it what's the price
tomorrow
it will tell you really it won't be
correct but it will tell you
we do have a channel on our discord
about stock market prediction it's
easily the most exciting channel
i will check it out promise um check it
out no
you can't just not say prayer work you
have to give proper recognition what
about artificial curiosity what about
predictive really
[Laughter]
next layer wx plus b smaller than zero
stop please please please enough good
guys
enough of you good guy really
which model is this i am state of the
art do you
have the slightest idea how little that
narrows it down
okay so i watch all your videos and i
know them all by heart
all of them by heart and also i know
them in reverse and
basically i was wondering how much
does improvement over state-of-the-art
mean like
really it means one paper
but like percent wood it's
it's if you have if you write the magic
letters s-o-t-a
with the first and the last capitalized
the reviewers magically will
lift from their chairs and up to the sky
where they'll be treated to a massage
come back down
their hand will be guided to the accept
button
researcher is often obtaining sota
performance
by replacing rnns with transformers
future is now old man future is now
yeah the funny part is this is already
old
it's already older yes now people are
replacing convnets with
transformers and getting state of the
art
i never quoted a transformer yeah never
did you
from scratch no see no also i meant from
scratch
of course what do you think about
multi-head attention ah
that's the best it's just the best the
best kind of attention
the best kind of attention between any
kind of attention
yeah and uh also like sometimes i i
i think it's better than i don't know
eating
and sleeping what's your favorite
transformer multi-head attention
i would also count bumblebee
bumblebee it's from the movie
it's a car that can also be a robot
transformers optimus
i have been this guy
and i have been this guy yeah sometimes
i'm very like on some papers
i must say but i'm very very very
um how's it called bloody yeah somebody
yeah
yeah i just don't do anything they're
getting ready there's a little bit of a
joy
right yeah and just being what's once
the last review i did it was like
okay ah this was already done in and i
decided i
took the time to put the citation of
like 10 papers to do this
one two four all of them
just to destroy them yeah
but yeah it was not a good paper that is
from
xkcd and when you train predictive
models on input from your users
it can leak information in unexpected
ways
the person types in long live the
revolution our next meeting will be
at and the model completes it to the
docks at midnight on june 28th
[Laughter]
see the interesting thing is that this
the meme is about or the comic is about
i'd say six months old at least
but just this week a paper came out
doing exactly this
yeah crazy yes yeah this is like perfect
prediction
where should i find a paper is there a
video link to that uh
it's going to be yeah there's going to
be a video on that paper
why are you late i um
had to put
on gabbert oh okay
so this is this is cat or croissant and
i have actually made
for you a presentation where i'm going
to
test you first one
cat or crossover i was a cat i was
definitely a cat
indeed a cat okay next one that was a
croissant
damn you're good okay
elsa it was a cat
okay that was a croissant that was a
croissant okay next one
was ever a very good croissant or a cat
a very good croissant though
it was a cat normal people can't go to
the gym to work out because of lockdown
me and ml engineer phd students
europe's reviewers a well-written
research paper
our model is simple and easy to
implement implementation
when you hear someone still referring to
europe says nips
now that's a name i haven't heard in a
long time i got used to that
the question is do you say i was at nips
or do you neep some sounds weird now now
it's on i know
it sounds weird yeah yeah i had the same
experience why
yeah we did it we time traveled
but to what here let's ask that guy over
there
hey what's the coolest deep learning
framework
tensorflow we're in 2016.
paddle paddle 2021 it's going to happen
i believe it
paddle paddle 2021 it's best framework
when you're a python user and it's been
five minutes since you haven't told
anybody
how it's better than tensorflow i don't
know
i don't even know what you use yannick
but i mean i i have to say i'll
i'll just don't ask just not to get
angry at you otherwise
and you'll stick with matlab well this
one
can also be applied to other things yes
we'll make the title of this video meme
review is all you need
there's a paper on your desk saying like
logarithmic bounds and where to find
them
yeah yeah no it's like ah yeah
it's like fantastic generalization
measures and where to find them
you should be like electro shocked when
you submit this to archives like
i think i think they got very accepted
click bait oh it's also by banjo the the
brother okay by torch google
tensorflow enable eager execution
this was a disaster a design i didn't
know tensorflow eager mode so pi torch
was
is always like dynamically constructing
your graph you explained it to me yeah
yannick you don't remember but you
explained it to me probably
i actually gave summer schools on this
topic summer school
yeah the best kind of summer school
if you actually look at the tensorflow
source code it is
littered with if statements if
eager then this part piece of code if
not
eager than this piece it's like two
frameworks just bumped
together into one because they wanted to
copy pythord so much
and uh so in a weird statement at that
time
ai was actually full of if statements
now i understand the mean way better see
it it gives it a new meaning
theoretically well understood the deep
learning practices
all the pages are the black quantified
no yeah
deep learning is is not a thing this is
me this is totally
it's gonna be it's gonna be fuzzy logic
i told you what do you think the future
is gonna look like
you